it is possible to stay off the grid but
I would recommend that you get a job
that has nothing to do with
communicating with other people because
quite frankly I mean part of me I do
sometimes feel sorry that the career I
chose journalism is if you're a
journalist and you want to stay off the
grid you're screwed
you are absolutely screwed like goodbye
you might as well just you might as well
start working in healthcare because it's
just it's not going to happen for you
and and and it's there are a lot of
exciting things happening with it but I
mean for example Tina Brown's Daily
Beast best example of what the future of
journalism is that I have ever seen it
is it is like a shining light in
journalism in my opinion and it is what
you are gonna see with that site
mark my words three years from now
everyone's gonna be like the daily beast
that is what journalism is now it's
going to be the new New York Times it's
frightening to think about it but that
is just the truth if you're shy listen
you learn to adapt privacy wise I have
learned to adapt privacy wise I know now
what to keep off and what to put on I
made a lot of mistakes when I first
started that is going to happen to
everyone I'm a canary in the coal mine
as it were and what will happen is that
there will be a whole host of people the
frontline that will make all these
mistakes and other people will learn
from them and it won't be perfect but it
you know there will there will come a
point and this is a very interesting
book by Clay Shirky well I'm I think you
probably have interviewed here I'm
guessing he talks about the gap between
when technology is invented and when
it's completely integrated into society
and that gap there's a there's chaos
which is why we decided to name our
company non Society because we realized
Megan Mary and myself realized that we
were on the frontline that there weren't
any rural society the word society means
rules by which you interact with other
people and we realized there were no
rules for this medium people are asshole
funny and they think that that's okay
because it's you know I mean people said
it's the Wild West out there I wish
there were less hackneyed term but
that's really what it's like